- Hey guys, I'm Curly.
- I'm Jazzmyne.
- And we're here for Queer
Prom 2018 in New York City.
- Woo, and we're about to
go meet the court, let's go!
(screaming)
(upbeat music)
- [Teo] Hello.
- [Man] Hey Teo, how's it going?
- [Teo] Hi, I'm great.
- Well I wanted to introduce to my friend
who had some news for you.
- Hi!
- Oh my God!
- How are you?
- Oh, my God, what, oh my God!
- So we wanted to tell
you that you were selected
and you are coming to New York to go to
Buzzfeed's Queer Prom.
- You're serious?
Oh my God.
I feel like I came out to
myself when I was like, 10.
(laughing)
I was 10 years old like, okay,
I wanna say this, why can't I say it?
People are telling me I shouldn't
be saying something like this.
People are telling me I
shouldn't feel this way,
so I didn't feel comfortable enough
to share how I was feeling,
and I guess it made me
a really angry person.
My father is something.
He's very one of those people that's like,
my kids are queer so I love queer people.
And he says things like,
oh, you wanna act like a man,
then I'm gonna treat you like,
I'ma talk to you like you're a man
so you better man up, you better do this.
And just because I identify as a trans guy
doesn't mean I gotta be super
masculine 'cause I'm not.
(laughing)
Hi, so I'm in my room, it's late at night,
and I just realized that there's
only five days 'til Queer Prom.
Living in Philly is many different things.
It's really cool to be
around music creators,
but at the same time,
the people who I like to
surround myself with sometimes
don't like me to be around
them, which can suck.
(singing)
I spend a lot of time in
the music scene in Philly,
and it gets kinda scary,
it gets kinda upsetting,
because a lot of the music business
is homophobic and transphobic
and sexist and horrible.
I had my sister at home and
she was much more of a support system.
She is probably the only person
who I know that's always
supporting me like, my whole life.
- Well, for me, I'm already queer.
I came out as pansexual a long time ago,
and everybody wasn't accepting of it.
You came out twice, though.
- Twice?
- You came out twice, yeah.
- I guess it happened.
- You came out twice, but when
you came out as gay first,
I was just like, okay, I know,
and then you're like, okay.
And then the second
time, you were just like,
I'm transgender, and I'm like,
alright, what's your name,
what are your preferred
pronouns, alright, that's fine.
(peaceful music)
- I came out to my mom in
a 7-Eleven parking lot.
(laughing)
We were fighting, I think
over transgender rights,
or something, and I was like,
well Mom, I'm gay, and
then I ran out the car,
went to 7-Eleven, went back to the car,
and we stayed there crying
for at least an hour.
All the 7-Eleven people
probably think we're crazy
but, I'm so sorry, yeah, I love my mom.
I wish she was here.
So, we're getting ready to board
our flight to New York
for Buzzfeed's Queer Prom.
- [Eva's Mom] Abelena's my only niece,
and she is the same age
as my daughter, Eva.
- It means everything to be
able to be here for your mom,
who loves you so much,
and even though she's in
Nashville accepting an award,
I am texting her like crazy
and sending her pictures
and she's here with you every
minute, and we love you.
- How has me being gay
affected our relationship?
- I think we're closer now.
I think you are able to open up more,
and, which is a good
thing, it's a good thing.
- Yeah.
It's taken me a long time to be able
to say I have a girlfriend out loud,
'cause all the repercussions
that can happen
in high school and the
cruelty of kids and I,
honestly wanted to protect
her more than myself
so I didn't want her to go through
what I gone through in my past.
And it was hard 'cause
I like her a little bit,
you know, and it was hard
not being able to show
our love and affection out in public,
in a place that's supposed to be safe,
like a high school dance.
- I don't feel protected
as a queer person,
especially as a queer person of color.
I think at my school specifically,
for the number of out queer
and trans people that we have,
there's very little protection
in terms of enumerated policy.
I've arguably done more work
for LGBT inclusivity at my school
than some of the people who make
the policies at my school, who,
it's their literal job to do this work,
and, so it's been frustrating.
Ohio is, it's quaint.
It's one of those places where
everyone thinks it's just corn.
There's also a lot of
racism and homophobia,
in addition to corn.
When I came out, I didn't have
an official, guys, I'm queer.
I just started dating a
girl, and everyone was like,
oh, I didn't know you were gay,
and I'm like, well I'm not.
And they're like, what are you?
And I'm like, haven't figured it out yet.
I think, in terms of coming
out as gender-nonbinary,
that was a little bit more difficult.
I got more of, well I
don't know what that means,
well can you explain that to me,
well, are you sure that
there's more than two genders,
and I think people get
caught up on the pronouns,
like, oh, the different pronouns,
it's not grammatically correct.
In reality, they're not
seeing a person saying like,
hey, I'm different than
what you think I am,
I need you to accept that.
Mom, how do you feel about me
going to Buzzfeed's Queer Prom?
- I'm happy for you,
I'm glad you got picked,
'cause I know that was something
that you really wanted.
I've learned a lot,
and I'll say it's really made
me think about my life and,
here it comes.
High school was really difficult.
I thought that I had it rough
because I was the nerd at school.
I was mistreated by people but,
they really did all
say wrong, really wrong
and, I'm sorry, I'm sorry that
you had to go through that.
- For reference, school was hard because,
we'd have teachers that are like,
we're trying to find a
different class for Ose to be in
because, you know, they make
the teacher uncomfortable,
or, we understand that this
teacher makes you uncomfortable
because they don't represent your identity
but we're not gonna do anything about it.
And, they'd been like, oh,
we're gonna suspend you,
like, oh, we're gonna
put you in detention,
or we're gonna switch your schedule,
and never getting to
the route of the problem
and, so yeah, I really appreciate my mom.
Yeah.
- And you can be yourself and turn up.
(laughing)
- I can turn up?
- Yeah.
- Okay, I'll do that, I'll
turn up, I will turn up.
- Okay.
- So there's only, like,
three days left until I go to New York.
I've never flown and now here I am
graduating and flying out to New York.
What a way to start adulthood.
Hi, my name's Paige,
I'm 18 years old and I come
from Las Vegas, Nevada.
I came out to my aunt,
she's my support system.
I told her everything.
That's where I would go to
escape from my situation at home.
She's like that backbone
that I needed growing up.
So I questioned my grandmother
and my aunt, actually.
Those are the first two
people I questioned.
I was like, what is a lesbian?
'Cause I was like, what is that?
'Cause that's what I was told that I was,
and I was like, yeah I like
girls, there's a term for it?
So when I came out that weekend
after sitting there and contemplating,
a 12-year-old sitting
on the couch just like,
okay, I went up back upstairs and I said,
you know what, you're right, I am.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey Sidney.
- Oh, you caught me in deep thought.
(laughing)
- I went to elementary
school, middle school,
and high school with the same kids,
so everyone just grew
up knowing each other.
We don't have a LGBT club.
We did and they got rid of it.
When they got rid of it,
I was kinda disappointed.
I was like, you're serious, right?
You can't do that.
You're basically telling us
we can't express ourselves,
so I grew up my junior year
and senior year without one,
and you just saw this
decline of people who
didn't wanna be as open about it at school
and we just didn't have the club anymore.
- I was born in Boston.
I lived there for my first
two years of my life,
and then I moved to Barbados.
(calming music)
Part of growing up there
was, in the culture,
it's not okay to be who I was,
so it was a very, very
private part of my life.
I moved back when I was 10 years old.
My school was an all boys,
New England Prep School,
so take with that what you will.
It's predominately white,
predominately straight,
so there wasn't much of a community
for two aspects of my identity.
So it became difficult to
really exist in that space,
so that's when I turned to
theater after my freshman year.
It's something that I
ended up really enjoying
and it became a huge part of my life.
- Well, I have some news.
- Yeah?
- Well we're super excited that
you're gonna come hang with us.
And I love your story.
- Oh my God.
- We're so stoked.
- So you're good to go, like you can come,
you're free, and you're
gonna bring your mom, right?
- Yeah.
Oh my God.
- Then she can come?
- I wish I had told my mom first,
because that's the only opinion
that I really cared about.
I remember the story
very, very distinctly.
December 6, 2017, we're talking
about one of my friends,
who was going through a really
difficult time in her life,
and I was asking my mom for advice
on how I could help her and
help her through this time,
and she was talking about how,
oh I just wish kids would
feel more comfortable
telling their parents
things, so I was like,
oh, this might be a sign,
lemme just do it right now,
and it was the longest pause ever
and it finally set in and she
laughed and was like, I know.
- I knew.
I just knew.
I am happy that he's able
to come out his comfort zone
and say who he really is, not
being ashamed, and being free.
I respect that a lot about him.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I went to prom,
I went to prom twice,
and I was with a singular
person that I liked
in a space full of people
that made me uncomfortable.
- Like if I wanted to
bring a boy or something,
I don't think that there would
be space for me to do that.
- Do I go, do I get judged?
I don't want that
judgment on my shoulders.
- It was ugly.
I lived, I survived that day.
I made it.
(laughing)
I have a good prom coming!
- [Unison] Queer Prom!
- I'm excited to meet them.
- [Jazzmyne] I'm like,
so excited to meet them.
- Okay.
- Welcome to New York!
(cheering)
What's up?
- I'm here at Buzzfeed, like, holy crap.
This is amazing!
- Surprise.
(laughing)
- This is just an adrenaline rush.
It's like, whoa.
- We have a little surprise for you.
We got some new little
phones for you guys.
- [Curly] So these phones will be
so y'all can document the Queer Prom,
and then also y'all can
take them home afterwards.
(cheering)
- I don't think anyone understands
how excited I am to be here.
- I think probably I'm most
excited about is the energy.
I never feel like I can just
go and socialize somewhere,
and I feel like it's gonna be a place
where I can just talk to
anybody and them be like,
hey, what's up?
- I think this is the first
time that I would probably
be in a room with that
many people who are queer.
- Exciting.
- I am so excited to
just click with everybody
and run around and touch everything.
If it's shiny, I'm touching it.
- Alright, everybody, make a silly face!
Three, two, one.
- [Unison] Queer Prom!
(funky music)